for the dressing wrap a whole bulb of
garlic in foil and roast it in a hot
oven next add top and tail green beans
to salted boiling water and cook for
just a couple of minutes this is called
blanching and keeps the beans
deliciously crunchy strain the beans and
refreshing cold water this stops the
cooking process so they stay crisp and
green next remove your garlic from the
oven cut off the head and squeeze out
all the glorious garlic which has gone
creamy mellow and divine in the oven
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of Dijon mustard and sweet
runny honey season and pour in a good
glug of olive oil then whisk
at the crunchy blanch green beans and
top with toasted almonds for a lovely
nutty note and crunchy texture mix well
and serve heavily must have been a great
with a hit of mellow roast garlic
stunning green beans dressed to
perfection now the exciting part with a
dress the sellers nice spoon of dressing
in to the papaya don't hold back with
the herbs they'll really help make the
filling vibrant fresh and aromatic
finally it's alive